hi this is Ted balageru the reason TV
reporting guerrilla-style from the
sundance film festival in park city utah
I'm Graham I'm a bartender here at No
Name saloon there's a lot of ethology
about what you can and can't do in Utah
alcohol wise what kind of questions you
usually get from out-of-towners get a
ton of questions about what real beer we
conserve and what what it is and it's
all called a state import here it means
it's gone through the liquor store and
they've taxed it on any real beer and
then a lot of people trying to get
doubles all the time and which is also
illegal here in Utah so so what happens
from someone else for a devil I just
simply explained that i would love to
serve it to them but sadly i can't and
you can't have two shots of the same
alcohol served any given person any
given weekend so you can't get like a
double shot but can you get like two
singles for the same person nope not you
can't have a cocktail with the shot of
the same alcohol you can have a vodka
crane and a shot of whiskey on the side
if you want but you can't have two shots
of vodka there you can have announced
even if they narrow that one person is
drinking it they can order to separate
drinks to three different kinds yes
exactly well it's not too different
cocktails but you know will serve to
cocktails oh it's just yeah you can't
for any given person they can't get too
much goes do you think that works no not
at all I to get just this time consuming
for both the patron and the employee but
they still end up getting drunk is what
I've seen
special needs la people coming hey yo yo
the common effort with a vengeance made
and what about things like Mike's Hard
Lemonade kind of fruity alcoholic
beverages ya know the state also banned
those no Mike's Hard Lemonade nazima no
wine coolers anything like that pulled
him out of the state completely but no
one was really buying Jima anyway right
actually we sold not a ton but a fair
amount of mics are eliminated I don't
know anywhere that serves Zima luckily
at the supermarket what are you going to
find and what are you're not going to
find you're going to find three two
alcoholic content beer it's all near
beer there's nothing real there so can
you tell the festival people what are
they like in general oh look at some
demanding people in here but uh you know
it's now look at me Here I am sir me
right now and they're generally drinking
higher in doubt go as well because when
I got south park episode it's not too
far